I think it's really important for kids
to take care of themselves and make that
a priority not you know and I know some
people say you know that that seems
selfish that's not I mean you know you
can take care of yourself and not be
selfish you can make sure to prioritize
how you feel and and I think that's
something I didn't do for a very long
time and I'm doing that now and it feels
great you know exercising I go to
therapy every week I think it's like
it's just something to make your life
better and think about that because we
only get one life and and you know you
got to live your own you got to do as
much as you can to make sure that you're
feeling healthy mentally and physically
and that's something that doing a lot
more of now and it's and it's nice but
exercise isn't the only thing Arielle
winter is doing on her journey to
becoming happier and healthier I've
exercised before but I've never really
actually wanted to like do it frequently
I never really actually cared so much
like I went and did things but like I'd
send the women's health articles that I
I I couldn't like see any results before
because I was on medications that
wouldn't do anything like that and it
was it was really difficult for me and
now that I've changed medications beyond
something different it's nice because I
go to the gym and I can see result
tonight actually I feel healthier like I
feel like you know it's it's nice I do
that I've tried all sorts different
things like I tried tennis recently I've
tried softballs and that's something I
never would have tried before excited
just like oh I'm not nuts for tea I'm
not anything like that but I've tried
those things now I'm getting into more
sports and it's just different
I'm just open to way more things I used
to be I used to be like no I'm not gonna
try that now I'm I'm open to et caught
up with the 21 year old actress at the
kids in the spotlight charity event
which benefits foster care youth a cause
that hits close to home for winter well
it's an incredible organization first of
all I started getting into it I think
probably like seven months ago because
ty had been talking about it for a
really long time and it was something I
told ty was really important to me I
think empowering foster youth is really
important because you know we don't have
tons of things for them to do and I feel
like it's kind of like this is something
through filmmaking and and whatever it's
something that empowers them to be able
to
move for it and make new skills and also
just do something that makes them happy
and something that keeps them interested
and wanting to do something with their
future just anything in general and I
think it's just a really wonderful
organization the people who run it are
so lovely and I know it means a ton to
tie and it means the same to me because
I think it's just bossy because I've had
I've had experience with that in my own
life and so for me I think it's just
really something that spoke to me and
struck me as something that I think is
really important to support and speaking
of ty burrell the Modern Family co-stars
are gearing up to say goodbye to their
ABC comedy after 11 seasons it's really
sad to think about that we'll do a final
party and that'll be it
so I don't really know if I'm privy to
what we'll do then but I hope we get it
they don't really think there's anything
for me like anything material that I
want to take from the set because the
things on our set aren't what really
makes it for me it's the people I work
with and I know that I'm gonna keep in
touch with them so I don't think there's
any like a souvenir I'd want to take
that I'd look at and that would remind
me of all the memories I think it's just
the memories of the people in the
experience for me
[Applause]
[Music]